awesome how's everyone doing tonight
cool I'm excited to be here with you so
today I'm gonna tell all of you a little
bit about a story of how I started my
journey in entrepreneurship back up give
a little back story so I grew up in
Scottsdale Arizona yeah
and growing up I was always fascinated
in technology my dad worked at IBM and
one day brought home a computer for my
brother and I and said you know here's a
computer we're gonna put this over here
in the computer room
you can use the computer for 30 minutes
a day and the older I got those 30
minutes turned into an hour a day and
then turned into a few hours on the
weekend and I became obsessed with that
computer more specifically I became
obsessed with what I could do inside of
that computer I was really interested in
all the video games that my brother was
playing and then I said you know why
don't we go and create our own video
game so my brother who's two years older
than me we would sit down on the weekend
and we would learn how to code and we
would just go to Google and I don't know
if any of you remember w3schools dot-com
but it taught us how to it taught us
what HTML was what CSS was what was
JavaScript we started just teaching
ourselves little by little once I
graduated from high school my brother
and I went to our parents and we said
you know we've been learning a lot about
technology and we think that this whole
coding thing is really really cool we
want to take this summer in between my
high school and first college year to go
and start our own business my dad came
back and my dad again being a very
traditional guy who climbed the
corporate ladder said if you kids want
to go start a business you need to move
out of the house and learn how to be
financially independent so me at 18
years old was like all right I don't
know how I'm gonna do this but I've got
savings saved up from birthdays and from
chores and all this other stuff and my
brother said I've also got savings saved
up from birthdays and chores and all
this other stuff growing up so we
decided to pool our resources which was
about three thousand dollars and decided
to move to South Central Los and
when I was 18 and he was 20 years old we
rented out an apartment that was a
two-bedroom apartment we realized that
if we had rented out one of the other
bedrooms
it went from 900 bucks a month to 450
for the two of us and then if we split
that there was 225 a piece and we could
do that for three months in between high
school and college so we were gonna try
and make this work so we said all right
parents we're gonna do this packed up
our bags and move to South Central when
we got there we started our first
company and we had this crazy idea we
wanted to allow people to store all
their usernames and passwords on one
site and log in to everything we just
want to use name and password that's
what we wanted to build that summer we
called it my social cloud and that
summer we were working away building the
first prototype coding day in and day
out living off of Doritos and ramen and
finally one day I logged into Twitter
and saw to eat and the tweet said come
meet me in Miami for intimate cocktails
donate two thousand dollars to charity
and the tweet was from Richard Branson
Richard Branson for all you who don't
know started the Virgin group so I
immediately took that email address that
he gave right after the donate two
thousand dollars and I said hello my
name is Stacy Ferrara I am 18 years old
so I am not legally old enough to drink
cocktails but but I would love to come
to Miami and meet you with my brother
were two young aspiring entrepreneurs
and we would love to learn from you
about how you started your businesses we
stayed up all night and got an email
back from the secretary she said yeah if
you two can donate $4,000 and be in
Miami in 48 hours then you can meet him
and I was sitting at my small little
desk in the one bedroom that I had and I
was like great here's an opportunity too
bad I don't have $4,000 but did the only
thing that I could think of to do at the
time knowing that it is a once in a
lifetime opportunity and I called my dad
and I said hey dad I know that you don't
know what Twitter is and I also know
that $4,000 is a lot of money but this
is a once-in-a-lifetime opportunity to
go meet Richard Branson can I please
borrow $4,000 from you my dad at this
point probably thinks I'm crazy
but he came back on the other end of the
phone and he said Stacey here's the deal
write up a proposal for me why do you
need the money
where is this money going and most
importantly what's your payment plan how
are you gonna pay me back
so I write up this proposal for my dad
and send it off over email and I get a
call back from him and he says all right
here's the plan this is a lesson in
money management you can either take a
four thousand dollar loan from me with
the stipulation that you have to pay me
back in three months before you step on
college campus you have to pay me back
or you don't take the loan and again
kind of running through the list of
things in my brain of you know what are
all the things that I can sell if if
something doesn't come out of this you
know how am I gonna pay this back but I
said alright this is again a
once-in-a-lifetime opportunity I just I
have to do this
so borrowed the $4,000 got on a plane
and flew to Miami to meet Branson over
the course of the next two nights we got
to spend a lot of time with Branson most
importantly the first night was a room
of eighteen people who had responded to
the tweet and all of us got to go around
talk about our business and what we were
working on right after that I went up to
Branson and asked him if he could write
down his personal email address on a
piece of paper and he did he wrote down
an email address and handed it to myself
and my brother my brother immediately
took it from me and looked at it and
kind of inspected it and then he went
over to the Branson's secretary and said
is this really is this really his email
address
and she was like yeah that is so keep it
close from there my brother and I flew
back to South Central LA we finished up
the prototype for my social cloud and
then sent an email to Branson and said
here's what we've built so far we'd love
your advice on how you think we should
take this to market we got an email back
from him
shortly thereafter he said this is great
I don't do a ton in technology this was
back in 2011 so he said you should meet
my friend Jerry Murdock who runs insight
Venture Partners a week later Jerry got
on a plane and flew out to LA to meet
with my brother and I and drilled us on
our business asked us hundreds of
questions but what was the business
model how did we plan to monetize how
would we built the platform so far what
was the product roadmap how did we plan
to keep building it what were we gonna
do about school we were so young we
answered all these questions and after
answering them we went out to dinner
that night and Jerry said that he
Branson and another investor Alex Welch
would all invest 1.2 million dollars in
our business that's really what
kick-started my own entrepreneurial
journey taking a risk not being afraid
of what could happen and asking the
question what do I lose if I don't do it
that has that lesson has followed me all
throughout my journey we went on then to
build my social cloud over the course of
two years we sold it in 2013 to
reputation.com just here in the Bay Area
after that I went on to publish a book
called 2 billion under 20 before
starting my next company Forge the
lesson that I want to leave all of you
with today is it only takes one thing
emailing one person who you might say
why would this person ever respond or
even just looking at your Twitter feed
or sometimes asking the big question can
I please loan money from you
can I please borrow this saying yes as
opposed to saying no has made all the
difference in my life so take those
risks and say yes thanks
[Applause]